this accusation audit we should maybe
talk about that a little bit that's that
was
something i found now you derived that
from your analysis of courtroom behavior
of lawyers
i remember correctly well it added to it
i mean you know seeing it working
in different in different areas it
definitely added to our thinking
what is it if you don't mind
yeah well you know it's first of all
it's uh you know the
the lawyers would call it getting out
the uglies in advance
you know if you gotta if you've got a
witness that there's some ugly things
about you bring it up first
let the jury reconcile themselves to it
before they listen to anything else
you know i worked with some great
prosecutors when i was with the fbi
southern district in new york
now in in in business it's
understanding what the negatives are in
advance what's crazy is when we begin to
proactively get out in front of them
like if i get if i could get some let's
say you got no negative
about me at all but i'm getting ready to
say something that you're not gonna like
i'll say look you're gonna think i'm a
real jerk for bringing this up
and then when i bring it up it'll have
far less impact you'll never know what i
headed you off from
and that's why we get really aggressive
with going after the negatives early on
and calling them up
yeah so the accusation audit allows you
to lay out on the table
all the weaknesses of your position and
your character for that matter
and so there's a variety of reasons that
that might be useful
one is that by indicating your
willingness to
[Music]
admit to these faults you show that the
faults are small enough so that someone
could admit to having them
that's the first thing and the second
thing is you
show yourself as someone who's larger
than their fault
because they're willing to admit to them
right so you minimize the fault in some
sense even though you're presenting them
accuracy
accurately you minimize their emotional
impact and you decrease their emotional
impact
and you increase the
the integrity of your own character at
the same time and again these two things
that should be done honestly not as a
matter of technique
if you do an accusation audit it should
be a genuine wife
and you should be doing it in part so
that you this is my understanding anyway
so that you are also
as aware as you get as aware as you need
to be
of the shortcomings you have in the
negotiation